by the way one part of the report reads
that one patient suffered a perforated
small bowel and a soft tissue infection
after Dr Roxy was looking into the
camera while performing lipos section
this seems like a will Ferell movie not
a real life Dr Roxy imagine waking up
from a surgery and watching your doctor
doing this weird
dance are you kidding me right now put
me out again I'm going to need some more
of that anesthesia for sure it's a weird
world we're living in man that's the
most I can say regarding this you
know what else is weird the fact that
you're not following my page come on man
go ahead like this video follow for more
content later